opens the committee of conference
on house bill 187
an act relative to the emergency powers
of the commissioner of health and human
services and relative to the membership
of the oversight committee
on health and human services and i think
we
know that there's only two spots of
disagreement the rest of it is
is pretty easy if you've got your side
by side it's
lots of blank spaces so if you would
turn please to
this has to do with the oversight
committee
which i chair and my immediate
and the only change that
i see is that
line 7
um when it came out of the house it
asked for two members of the senate
and the senate amended it to three
um lots of interest
we are interested senator sherman uh
well it two is uh
actually the original number was three
and it was dropped to
two in statute i think it was last year
yeah and so
i think this was partially at the
request of the department partially
requested senate because you know if you
put three on you might get one
that's just an attendance issue so it
would be
great
and i think when we were talking
you and i mr chairman about drafting in
the house
i simply said i never had three ever
so perhaps we could just put it at two
because i was concerned about issues of
a quorum
but i'm no longer concerned about issues
of the quorum because
the house can appoint alternates and if
the house has alternates i can get five
people where you can get five people
into the room and that means that
we can to the limited extent the
committee votes on anything so i
i think that going back to three of the
senate prefers it that way
makes sense to me outside i'm good with
this
yeah okay the only thing
i could please the only thing i'd ask gm
is whether there's a desire on the
senate side
to
we don't normally do that what we
normally do is that if someone
can't attend then the senate president
will appoint a temporary replacement
you know for that day and then right
so the senate office usually takes care
of it
would that be considered legitimate even
though it is
not going into the law here well the
thing
is is that senate president is the
person who gets to choose who the
representatives are
right and as long as he signs it and
says for this day that's my
representative
it meets fully the law all right we had
a senator missing
uh last friday and no replacement had
been
named so that just simply means the
senate
members of oversight would be would be
reviewed in this procedure
well what your last friday thing is is
that
either the senator that was supposed to
be there didn't notify
the senate president's office or there
wasn't
uh sufficient things on the agenda that
the senate president thought it was
necessary to
you know put a replacement in for that
particular day it could be
a complicated thing that you're going
over and a
new replacement really wouldn't have the
background so
you know why would you do that if
there's any number of reasons i think
this had to
in fact it had to do with uh an airline
ticket that suddenly got moved up from
four in the afternoon to ten in the
morning and i think that is the reason
yeah
and if there's if there isn't sufficient
time to do it then
certainly the senate president can't do
that sure senator sherman
so if they let the senate president know
they can't be there for whatever reason
the fiscal committee is an example of
where we do that often
and depending upon the contents of the
meeting
if there is someone maybe we just want
to substitute one
one senator for another because of that
content
okay or if there is somebody absent
president will and i would just note
that senate practicing president than if
it
works for them works for me works for
you probably
and we have so few votes on this
committee you never know when jeff is
now the other item that involves a
change
will be on page four over to page
five in in my side by side um
if you do not have a side by side it's
and this has to do with um
any
[Music]
the oversight committee
stop an emergency order given by
the commissioner and you know for the
record i'm a
laurie chabonet groupie we've worked on
several things largely about
issues relating to churches and it was a
joy and a pleasure to work for her
or work with her maybe that was a slip
that worked with her
so any any thing going in here
is certainly not about the person of the
commissioner
but about duties of this and subsequent
commissioners
the feeling we had in health and human
services committee
and then this bill went to eda which
the representative is from was
that we the legislature
or members of the legislature
are a co-equal body to the executive
branch
with its departments and
secondly as many of us
especially the ones after 9 11 they are
for short-term emergencies they're for
blizzards or tornadoes or riots or
things like that
i don't believe that they were conceived
for pandemics
also as we saw the pandemic coming
through
things changed and well
married to a physician
i understand how when you say follow the
science sometimes the response is
as of which day or according to whom and
we saw that which in my mind didn't make
anybody venal
it just simply said what might be given
is an edict
and proves to be true it might be a
group of citizen legislators who have a
different opinion and they prove to be
true
so we want some
vehicle whereby we can say
we will review certain emergency orders
and let me say that i
see this also and perhaps especially as
a safety valve
because we have people from whom um
they don't want anybody to have orders
over them hell no i ain't going to do
what you're telling me to do
some of these people sit in the
legislature and to be able to know that
with a very high threshold
perhaps an emergency order
might be cancelled out my we were
talking earlier
i i wouldn't ever like to see it happen
but i think it has to be here to calm
some people down
and and so for that reason there's other
reasons too
our leadership republican house
leadership
wants a vehicle whereby an emergency
order of the commissioner
can be rescinded
and that's really going to be the sticky
spot here so that's my little
um for myself i would just say noted
and we probably the three of us probably
would want to get together and talk
about your proposal
um representative weber made a great
point if you would
not mind sharing it about how it came
out of our community uh
the the other thing that we were just as
you arrived
we were trying to track how this has
progressed through the house because
it went to two separate committees and
we were remembering
a provision that required a two-thirds
majority
to override any kind of decision
of the commissioner uh two thirds of
oversight
yeah oh i was i was thinking of a
two-thirds of the house
it was two-thirds vote double-check that
so
original document it is of the committee
okay so but but here's my suggestion for
you to think about
if if if you want to take some time and
think about it is
first of all think about super
majorities both in the committee and
potentially in the house
and secondly think about
a period of time that might be shorter
and more comfortable to people so that
we are not just
leaving a 90-day hiatus
so those are two things that i thought
might be subject
to discussion the other the other thing
that
is interesting with this is that of
course
if the house is bent on doing this the
house
the legislature not just the house but
the legislature
far easier in the senate than the house
actually the legislature can simply
convene itself and do whatever they want
and that's
item number one so if there's a
significant
sentiment this is the wrong direction uh
the legislature can take care of that
the other
the other thing is that the commissioner
can simply ask the governor to do it by
emergency order and
then we're in a different part of the
statutory scheme
so i throw all of that out senator
sherman
just my objection to
would act i mean we're not talking about
any specific action that may have
occurred during covet but what we saw
with cove
especially in the very early phase of
code
as you said the science was being built
it wasn't quite there and so
what the the decisions that were being
made were based on
the latest available silent science
but also turning to the expertise of
people like ben
chan and beth daley and
lisa morris all of whom
are specialists not just
in healthcare and is the state
epidemiologist
but also it's public health
and the success of our response
to kobat really was
the commissioner turning to expertise
in how do we manage a pandemic
for a health care standpoint and then
very rapidly
uh they created said mac which was the
price of standards of care committee
i sat on that and i've never sat
on a panel in new hampshire with more
expertise whether it was nursing home
experts
to child exercise
and that was the body that was making
recommendations
starting i think we started in may may
or june
what really concerns me about this is
that
you have this body of experts under
the commissioner under the governor in
and then you have a small body of
legislators who can shut that down
if i read this correctly if i write this
correctly for 90 days
with no definite oversight they can just
and or him depending on
the commissioner so i
i am very concerned about in the middle
of some kind of crisis which is where
the word emergency is
involved we have a legislative body
potentially with no expertise
being able to say no and the analogy i
would give is the person who presents to
the emergency room
with chest pain and you have a
cardiologist called in and he says
we need to go to the cath lab then you
call up
the president of the hospital who has
no expertise but is involved because
he's president
he says sorry i don't agree
all right and until then so i'm just
worried
if i could just finish him so i worry
about
the ability to completely block the
action
uh whether what's felt to be the
necessary response
a nimble science-based response on the
part of the commission
is the first name senator on this one
yes sir i want to shut this one down
it is clear to me that our position is
we prefer the senate position
if you want us to consider other
language it's probably not the language
that's
in your bill right now and i want to
make sure that we have time to get
through
all of your concerns before 9 30 because
many of us have
other meetings to attend so so please
consider
the senate language and whatever else
you have
if i could just add this too i mean this
is
going along at the same time as uh
household 417. so
i would like to think that a resolution
of 417
would make this a lot easier that
comedian conference meets at 11. let's
see what happens
so maybe we should come back tomorrow
can i be
uh representative can i interject with
the dna philosophy
sure as to what's going on here before i
as we'll have to leave it now
um to your point senator in the
discussion of the public health
officials
it's my understanding that the state of
new hampshire did no primary research
on pope so they were taking cues from uh
from a net
a higher level um so as far as their
response to that within the state of new
hampshire sure
but the science that's driving that
response was
was not primarily done in new hampshire
so so there's a
there's a little bit of of them
following the direction
and opinions of say the cdc or
or a national a national
science opinion on that but secondly to
to your point with the
with this the edna's concern is that you
know and i'm glad you brought up
417 in the governor whereas the concept
of having a check on the governor's
ability to
as far as the governor's emergency
orders the concern
here is that the health and human
services commissioner which is
in most people's or some people's view a
bureaucrat
would then now have power that is
actually
greater than the governor with it with
no ability to check
on the health and human services
commissioner and there is concern that
if the governor does have
restrictions and the legislature does
have the ability to
uh to check the governor's emergency
orders that that a
governor would then just use the health
and human services commissioner
to enact an emergency out order
that has less ability to be rescinded
and just use that as a vessel to get
what they want
let me well if i could just answer go
ahead i think having been in this
building a long time most
hhs commissioners answer to the governor
so i think in most circumstances your
concern would not be
significant but again i think
it for purposes of 187
we'd be best advised to see what happens
with 417
and then if there's an agreement on 417
then potentially
that kind of agreement could be
reflected in 187.
that's all i'm trying that sounds
reasonable um
i was asked i was not on the economic
task force that gave guidance but i was
asked by that group
to speak to dhhs
on behalf of churches having been an
episcopal priest for 47 years
as well as a legislator for five and
there were several occasions where they
called me they asked
there was one occasion when i called
someone and i said this isn't going to
stand yeah but that's the order
i said it is not going to stand because
it is treating churches in a manner that
is different from
other similar organizations and has been
adjudicated seven times and the churches
won six out of seven
oh well it will take us seven or eight
days to work this through the system
i said um we have a situation brewing
right now
they called back and said thank you
representative pearson we exceed
so there are times when somebody who
isn't a medical
expert can speak to an emergency
reporter
and prevail and i'm glad it was done on
that day i defused a lawsuit that's what
i wound up doing because there were
people ready to bring it
and they would have won it so just for
the record there may need to be some
vehicle
where others outside of the silo farm
can speak and speak with a reasonable
amount of intelligence
in both houses can be noticed senator
when do you propose we recess
too um i'm free
uh after the ceremony for the
uh tax credit things tomorrow probably
10 30 or so tomorrow morning i can do
tomorrow morning i have to be physically
somewhere
else i would have to be done by
11 30 i think well how many more of
these
items this is it that's it yeah
everything else is happy
so you're okay um and you said 417
that was being looked at today i loved
it 11 o'clock okay
so i could also do that i'm on the hbo
um
media conference that's tentatively
slated for 10.
i i don't have to be here tomorrow
morning
[Music]
how about wednesday wednesday's a
disaster for me
but i could do nine o'clock tomorrow
nine o'clock tomorrow no yes
nine o'clock is when the ceremony for
the awards are and i already have
i mean how long will the awards take it
shouldn't take but
uh an hour that's what they could
normally take when they're happy 10 30
would be
great for me 10 30. and senator
i'll be here if i can okay
um this will give us a chance to find
some language
um christina is there a room uh maybe
check with leadership leadership
okay good so we go into recess then